une france endettée est une france
dépendantes
il ya 2200 milliards de dettes on est
assis sur une bombe à retardement il ya
pas d'argent magique
le quoi qu'il en coûte cette réponse
économique
parmi les plus protectrices du monde se
poursuivra pour moi il ya deux phrases
qui n'ont absolument aucun sens c'est
here is no alternative
donc en fait il que des alternatives et
il n'y a pas d'argent magique
il n'y a que de l'argent magique y'a que
ça l'argent est magique par définition
il y en a pas du tout une quantité finie
comme ça et on n'est pas contraint par
cette quantité d'argent on est contraint
par la manière dont on peut utiliser cet
argent sert effectivement je peux
imprimer de l'argent et ont donné à tout
le monde mais qu'est ce que ça va
générer derrière est-ce que ça va
générer des bons et fait ce qu'on veut
qu'il arrive c'est ça la question
[Musique]
une économie capitaliste normal
consomment toujours plus de monnaie et
donc il faut trouver un moyen d'en
injecter dans le système on peut pas
faire uniquement avec les sous de
l'epargne c'est à dire l'argent déjà
existants ils font en injecter du
nouveau très régulièrement la banque
fabrique toujours de la monnaie quand
elle te le prête donc quand je vais
faire un crédit pour pourra obtenir cent
mille euros pour acheter un appartement
je prends pas les cent mille euros de
quelqu'un d'autre on me fabrique cent
mille nouveaux héros qu'on me prête et
ensuite il faudra que je les rendent les
banques quand on les rembourse pas ça ne
laisse pas les épargnants mais ça les
rapproche un petit peu plus de la
faillite
en fait il ya une espèce de mécanique ce
comptable qui s'enclenche qui fait qu'
elle sera proche de la faillite et donc
on peut imaginer un gouffre et donc à
chaque fois qu'on les rembourse pas un
petit peu on les pousse toujours un peu
plus vers le bord si à un moment donné
elles tombent les banques ton n'est pas
mon épargne y parle de tout le monde est
enregistrée dans la banque et donc quand
la banque tombent mal à les peindre des
gens disparaît et ça évidemment c'est un
vrai problème c'est pour ça qu'on veut
éviter de ne pas rembourser ces banques
là parce qu'on me rapproche de la
faillite de la banque centrale elle elle
ne peut pas la faire faire faillite elle
est la source de tout la monnaie et donc
la notion de faillite ne s'applique pas
à la banque centrale donc l on peut ne
pas la rembourser autant qu'on veut ça
lui fait ni chaud ni froid
[Musique]
il est économiquement et socialement
infiniment préférable de dégrader
temporairement les sols de publics pour
investir réarmer l'économie et repartir
de l'avant plutôt que de s'enfoncer dans
l'austérité laisser exploser le chômage
la misère et les drames humains
[Musique]
il ya un camp qui dit bah en fait avec
le co vide
on a perdu du pib on va faire 10 % de
pib ambre donc là le colosse qui porte
la dette laquelle état et ben il est
plus petit donc forcément la dette pèse
plus lourd mais en plus de ça on a été
obligés de s'endetter pour financer des
tas de trucs donc le poids de la le
poids de la dette augmente parce que la
dette augmente alors que l'état lui un
peu plus rabougri bon alors comment on
sort de cette situation là une idée
c'est on prend la dette qui est détenue
par la banque centrale
on l'a nul elle a tout de suite le poids
de la dette plus il devient plus petit
et c'est plus facile pour l'état de
continuer ceux qui sont pour
l'annulation de la dette 10
non seulement ça résout un problème de
refinancement donc c'est le poids de la
dette qui diminue quand le poids de la
dette est plus faible les marchés sont
plus enclins à dire ok j'ouvre finances
et la deuxième chose c'est de dire en
fait ça ouvre un peu la porte à des
techniques qu'on n'a jamais utilisé
jusqu alors mais qui pourrait nous
permettre de faire des tas de choses
très intéressantes
c'est à dire dire voyez on peut annuler
la dette mais du coup on peut aussi
aussi utiliser ce pouvoir de la banque
centrale pour faire plein d'autres trucs
donner directement des sous aux plus
pauvres pour réduire les inégalités
et où même donner directement des sous à
l'état pour qu'ils investissent
massivement dans la transition
énergétique et donc à mon sens ceux qui
défendent l'annulation de la dette
il essaye d'ouvrir la porte pour aller
plus loin derrière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
l'autre argument derrière qui est plutôt
soutenu mais pas forcément dit parce
qu'ils défendent qu'il faut pas annuler
cette dette
c'est qu'est ce que ça veut dire
concrètement des lunettes ça veut dire
qu'on ouvre la porte
ah bah oui la banque centrale peut
annuler des dettes
elle l'a fait pour l'état pourquoi elle
pourrait pas le faire pour une
entreprise voire pour des particuliers
et là du coup tout le monde peut annuler
sa dette c'est la fête
[Musique]
réduire notre dette publique est
nécessaire à la fois pour restaurer les
marges d'action aux façades possible
vous choque
et pour renouer avec une trajectoire qui
soit plus proche de ceux de nos
partenaires la zone euro ça veut dire
quoi annuler la dette ça veut dire ne
pas rembourser
c'est pas qu'on casse tout quand même
mais on leur mettrait clairement en
question l'idée que attention des sous
il y en a pas tant que ça il faut aller
demander aux financiers et c'est les
financiers qui disent ils veulent bien
prêter ou pas et c'est uniquement si un
retour sur investissement et ses onze on
s'extirpe un peu de cette de cette
notion financière et du coup on se donne
beaucoup plus de liberté de financer un
peu ce qu'on veut